how do you think about bitcoin as an
asset how do you think about inflation's
relationship to the bitcoin price does
inflation push bitcoin's price up just
talk to me a little bit about the kind
of decentralized digital currency and
where that fits into this view of the
world i don't know that it's an
inflation hedge but it inflation would
definitely be a tailwind
that's for sure i think that the best
argument for having bitcoin right now
has nothing to do with the price
direction i think that the best argument
for having bitcoin now i'm bullish on
the price long term i've owned bitcoin
for a long time a lot of people on fintu
it for some reason they think i'm a a
bitcoin bear that that's not really true
it's just that i've compartmentalized
the probabilities of the price of
bitcoin going up and then the
probability of bitcoin becoming global
money and replacing all fiat currency
those are two different sets of
probabilities
and people conflate the two
but i think the best reason for having
bitcoin right now is because there is a
very real chance that if you
value freedom
more than you value safety
that you are going to be kicked out of
the banking system you may be kicked out
of society i mean we see this happening
right now and i won't go into great
detail to keep it uh
youtube friendly
but uh we see a specific group in our
population that are now not allowed into
restaurants
or they're not allowed into gyms
and maybe they won't be allowed in
grocery stores or on airplanes in the
future
so we're getting this segregation of the
population and i think that especially
when you start layering on kind of a
dehumanizing effect of that group
then
i i think there's a higher probability
than zero
that that group
gets kind of excommunicated if you will
from the banking system and you know i
was talking to caitlyn long the other
day
on my show and we were talking about you
know how to buy bitcoin if you were
kicked out of the banking system she
says it would be very difficult if not
impossible to do legally so that's why
i've been telling people hey
even if you think the price of bitcoin
is going to go in half
who cares you got to have some just in
case you
you know get get uh kicked out of the
banking system because you're someone
who has
a dissenting view or a view that's
contrary to the mainstream narrative and
you need to keep some sort of purchasing
power with you as a plan b i think
that's the best argument for having it
right now but then i also think there's
a fantastic argument for
turning people on to bitcoin as a way to
open people's eyes to the risk of
tyranny
in our society
we see what's happening in australia
and i think as americans that should be
a wake-up call
because if that can happen in australia
it can definitely happen here as well
and so so many people on my channel uh
you know the one that got taken down yes
and reinstated they always say because i
always say at the end of the videos you
know we got to stand up and fight for
freedom fight for liberty and free
market capitalism
and they always say george well how do
we do that how do we do that we don't
have a channel with hundreds of
thousands subscribers we don't have a
big reach like you did i remind them
that i had zero reach back in 2019 but
also i say what you can do is just
simple things is first you've got to
isolate your friends and family members
into three different groups it's just
like sales
where you're going to have a third of
the group that's going to be receptive
to your message you're going to have a
third of the group that will just
completely ignore you no matter what you
say you could have a cure for cancer and
they won't listen to you
and then you have that third in the
middle that may be your average cnn
viewer but may at least have an open
mind and that's the group that you want
to focus on now i think the wrong way to
do that is just beat them over the head
with memes on facebook as to how they're
stupid or why they shouldn't be watching
cnn or how biden sucks or something i
think a better way to do that a more
tactical approach is to maybe just start
sharing some videos like yours or maybe
ron paul i always like to use ron paul
because he's such a nice guy and you can
tell by just listening to one of his
youtube videos for five minutes that he
is someone who is principled
and trustworthy even if you don't agree
with what he is saying so i said start
sharing some of those but then the next
thing i tell them is hey just introduce
them to bitcoin or introduce them to
gold right now i actually like bitcoin
better because unfortunately the way
we're hardwired as human beings
is we just want to get rich fast
and i'm sure you know so many people to
average joe and jane that really don't
understand why bitcoin is special they
don't understand the philosophy behind
it but they're attracted to it just
because they hear it on cnbc every 30
seconds or they see the price go from
let's say 40 000 up to 60 000 and like
holy cow how how do i how do i you know
they kind of get fomo but see that's a
great opportunity because even if that
fomo which i think is kind of negative
but regardless if it sinks the hook
and it gets them to understand why
bitcoin is interesting from a
philosophical standpoint then they get
introduced to austrian economics then
they get introduced to the freedom
and liberty movement and see then what
you've done by enticing them by the
price of bitcoin going up is three
months later you talked to them and now
all of a sudden they are also
standing up for freedom and liberty and
fighting this uh aggressive movement
towards tyranny that we have in the
united states